c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24
est la une ce soir la menace tu as dix
dans la file de djibo burkina faso des
hommes armés ont pris le contrôle de la
ville il y a deux semaines plus personne
ne peut ni entrer ni sortir les
populations sont encerclés et manque de
nourriture notre correspondant kalidou
sy a rencontré une jeune femme de djibo
absente pendant la prise de la ville
témoignage dans un instant et on
écoutera dans cette édition de nouveaux
témoignages d'étudiants rapatrier
d'ukraine les premiers marocains sont
rentrés chez eux hier et leur récit
n'est pas différent des autres et puis
notre correspondante à brazzaville nous
a également livré le témoignage d'un
jeune congolais dans la merde
ukrainienne est bloqué à kiev on
l'écoutera dans ce journal enfin nous
avons fait réagir ce soir le ministre
ivoirien de l'agriculture kobena kouassi
adjoumani sur la crise ukrainienne et
son impact sur le continent il est
également revenu sur les investissements
de son pays notamment pour soutenir la
production du cacao et de noix de cajou
thibault zone de non droit depuis le 17
février dernier cette ville du nord du
burkina faso est assiégée par les
groupes djihadistes des hommes armés qui
ont isolé la ville et ordonné aux
populations de partir djibo pourrait
faire face à une crise humanitaire sans
précédent
notre correspondant à ouagadougou
kalidou sy a pu rencontrer une jeune
habitante de djibo qui était absente au
moment de l'assaut écoutez son
témoignage
à ouagadougou a mis la tête une femme
seule et pour cause alors qu'elle se
rendait dans la capitale burkinabè pour
des examens médicaux le lendemain djibo
sa ville d'origine a subit un blocus
imposé par des hommes armés séparé de sa
famille restée sur place et dont elle a
très peu de nouvelles aminata espère
vite rentrer chez elle il se présente
dans notre quartier pu nous dire que il
nous donne un délai de 24 heures pour
partie actuellement d'un cinéma où se
trouve exactement ma famille dans la
prise j'ai joué à puis c'est là qu'ils
ont été ménagés ils sont en vie moi je
ne peux pas rester à voir je ne veux pas
toute ma famille se trouve à niveau
toute ma famille mon mari mes enfants ma
mère djibo une ville sous pression des
groupes armés depuis 2016 et le début
des attaques terroristes au burkina faso
capitale de la province du soum dans la
région du sahel
djibo est considéré comme l'épicentre du
jihadisme dans le pays aujourd'hui la
ville est totalement isolé plus personne
ne peut rentrer ni sortir l'eau se fait
rare et les prix des aliments flanc à
ouagadougou un collectif d'organisations
de la société civile du soum alerte sur
la situation humanitaire de djibo aucune
stratégie ou non une forme d'indemnités
et est développé pour le moment nous
espérons que dans les jours à venir
chacun s'est bousculé ras de son côté
afin de pouvoir venir en aide à cette
population qui est en train de mourir de
faim et de soif comme aminata de
nombreuses personnes ne peuvent
retourner à djibo depuis le début du
blocus une ville symbole du défi qui se
présente aux nouvelles autorités de
transition et au président dany bar
rétablir la sécurité dans l'intégralité
du territoire burkinabè
le burkina faso qui a désormais un
premier ministre au lendemain de
l'investiture du lieutenant-colonel
damiba comme président de la transition
albert ouédraogo économistes de 53 ans a
été nommé premier ministre par décret et
albert ouédraogo est également
universitaire à la tête d'un cabinet de
conseil et d'audit des entreprises
depuis 2007
et pour être complet sachez que le
procès des assassins présumés de thomas
sankara au burkina faso lors d'un coup
d'état en 1987 a de nouveau été reporté
à la demande de la défense dernière
s'interroge sur la constitutionnalité du
chef d'accusation d'attentât à la sûreté
de l'état après le dernier putsch du 24
janvier dernier
les premiers étudiants marocains de
retour d'ukraine sont arrivés hier à
l'aéroport de casablanca soulagé d'être
de retour au pays ils ont appelé les
autorités marocaines à poursuivre leurs
efforts de rapatriement ils témoignent
eux aussi de mauvais traitements et de
racisme écoutez
je demande au consulat de faire quelque
chose parce qu'en pologne les étudiants
sont traités avec violence et de façon
raciste ils ne peuvent pas sortir des
frontières ils auraient pu nous envoyer
des bus pour nous sortir de cette zone
mais ils n'ont rien fait les gens
marchent plus de 40 km parfois ils sont
obligés de jeter la nourriture pour
alléger le poids de leurs bagages pour
faire la route
certains meurent de froid dans les files
d'attentes les lacs à comparer aux
étudiants qui étaient à kharkiv kiev
notre voyage a été bon nous sommes
dirigés vers la frontière roumaine est
volontairement nous ont aidés avec le
propre agent en nous amenant avec leur
voiture dans un hôtel pour y passer la
nuit
sur le continent ils sont nombreux à
avoir des proches en ukraine c'est le
cas de david cailly congolais de mary
craignait neal a la double nationalité
depuis brazzaville il est en contact
tous les jours avec sa mère son frère et
ses deux soeurs qui tente d'échapper aux
bombardements de l'armée russe notre
correspondante à brazzaville rosie pioc
la rencontre est écouté
aujourd'hui ils ont fui la ville de
quartier ils sont meinau à kiev quand
j'apprends que bientôt
qu elle aussi sera envoyé par les russes
ça me faisait peur et me disent je n'ai
pas peur prix pour nous on t'aime nous
pensons à toi sois fort et prient
beaucoup pour nous ça va aller on va
s'en sortir on va se battre ça me fait
mal et je dois pas presque de prix oui
jours
c'est comme si
j'avais déjà perdu une partie de moi
au moins deux je fais grâce mes parents
sont encore vivants je les aime beaucoup
et je pense beaucoup à elle le pense à
mon frère je pense à mes deux soeurs je
vais les régions dès que possible après
ces événements aussi le faudra ici aussi
je pouvais avoir cette possibilité
maintenant d'aller des régions je serai
parmi les premiers à venir et être
combattre de leur côté
et se confier en ukraine à ses
conséquences sur le continent notre
invité kobena kouassi adjoumani ministre
ivoirien de l'agriculture et a réagi
tout à l'heure aux mauvais traitements
des ressortissants africains en ukraine
et en pologne il est également revenu
sur les efforts de son pays pour
relancer le secteur de la noix de cajou
et du cacao écouter
sur la question qui touche le caire
aujourd'hui
mon pays a déjà pris position
soutenir l union européenne et les etats
unis parce que nous estimons que ce qui
s'y passe
inacceptable
bombardé des populations civiles
des personnes innocentes
cela n'est pas bien et aujourd'hui comme
vous le dites nos populations qui sont
donc dans ce pays la subissent des
sévices cela n'est pas non plus normal
et je crois que son excellence monsieur
alassane ouattara président élu de côte
d'ivoire est un homme humaniste il a
instruit son ambassadeur qui est en
allemand donc de s'y rendre pour pouvoir
procéder à l'évacuation donc de nos
populations qui sont aujourd'hui dans la
détresse qui s'apparente même à l'amour
oui d'ailleurs les les ressortissants
ivoiriens seront bientôt de retour en
côte d'ivoire
votre pays a voté vous l'avait dit pour
la résolution de l'onu condamnant l'
invasion russe de l'ukraine de nombreux
pays africains se sont abstenus quoi ce
choix bon je ne peux pas y répondre tout
ce que je sais c'est que nous sommes
dans la mondialisation
ce qui touche aujourd'hui
l'ukraine peut toucher d'autres pays et
donc c'est tout à fait normal que nous
nous engageons à soutenir
toute action a rapport avec la
libération de l'ukraine qui aujourd'hui
est injustement attaqué donc la côte
d'ivoire fait partie du concert des
nations et nous avons pris position pour
soutenir l'ukraine il est tout à fait
normal que nous votions aussi
en faveur de cette proposition qui a été
faite alors vous l'avez dit nous sommes
en pleine mondialisation et les
conséquences vont toucher toute la
planète je pense particulièrement
à la question du blé vous êtes ministre
de l'agriculture on parle beaucoup de
pays qui s'inquiètent en afrique
notamment l'egypte l'algérie le nigeria
est ce que ça concerne aussi la côte
d'ivoire est ce que vous a senti ce ne
sont pas les pays africains qui
s'inquiètent même le monde entier
s'inquiète série l'europe aussi or vous
savez que encore d'ivoire nous faisons
de l'importation de blé à partir de
l'europe donc si l'europe est touchée
incontestablement nous aussi nous sommes
touchés et qui pour qui connaît ce que
le blé constitue dans la consommation
humaine on ne peut qu'être inquiet mais
je crois que d'ici là des solutions vont
être trouvées pour ne pas que la
catastrophe arrive alors sept ministres
de l'agriculture ans je les jette et on
a on parle de la crise ukrainienne ya
aussi la crise lié à la créa au colis 19
à la crise sanitaire dont on n'est pas
encore sorti qui a eu des conséquences
sur l'économie de la côte d'ivoire mais
de toute la planète
qu'en est il de votre secteur qu'en est
il du cacao qu'en est il de la noix de
cajou même si aujourd'hui nous sommes
premiers pays producteurs de cacao avec
2 millions 200 mille tonnes premier pays
producteur de noix de cajou avec un
million de tonnes pesc mais elle nous
sommes fortes ans atteint par le fait de
la couvée de 19 puisque le chocolat un
moment donné n'était plus tellement
consommer en raison de la conduite et ça
fait qu' il sera impacté les prix
heureusement que notre président avait
déjà pris des dispositions pour que
plus de 60 % donc du prix caf soit
reversée aux populations qui sont
productrices de cacao et de noix de
cajou en la matière aussi il ya eu des
subventions qui ont été donc donné pour
permettre à tous ceux qui sont dans le
domaine de la production de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un minimum afin de faire
face à leurs besoins quotidiens vous
avez de nombreux projets justement où
nous avons des projets déjà
des fonds ont été mis en place par
rapport à la proue vide pour soutenir
les producteurs à la base dans tous les
domaines d'activités agricoles et nous
aujourd'hui notre objectif c'est de
pouvoir également transformer ses
produits au niveau local il faut que
la valeur ajoutée puissent profiter aux
populations et aux proches des
populations
donc nous travaillons à faire en sorte
que les multinationales viennent
investir en côte d'ivoire et de cette
façon ce sera profitable et pour elle et
pour nos producteurs aussi
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci pour votre fidélité
merci aux équipes en régie merci notre
chef d'édition célia carrasso
[Musique]